hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we'll be talking about
truth and justice it's very hard to say
that phrase without thinking of Superman
right truth justice and the American Way
the American Way part never quite made
sense
Superman was from a different planet
after all he came from Krypton
he should be about truth and justice for
everybody in fact the American Way was
tacked on when the Superman radio serial
was being broadcast during World War two
and people thought it was really
important that the superheroes be on
America side in this conflict
it was later dropped in then it was
picked up again when we entered the Cold
War and ever since then Superman has for
some reason or another thought that
America was the best country but today's
guest dr. Alice dragger is all about the
truth and the Justice parts of this
motto and that's a non-trivial thing to
say because truth and justice although
both virtues are two different things
it may happen in the course of human
events that the search for truth and the
search for justice come into conflict
either apparent conflict or real
honest-to-goodness conflict and dr.
draggers specialty as a historian and
author is in human gender and sexuality
and more generally how our bodies relate
to ourselves as you might imagine this
is a set of hot-button issues when it
comes to humanity bodies and sexuality
so perhaps it's not surprising that dr.
Dreher has been involved in all number
of academic controversies her
controversies and her research involved
things like intersexuality
transgenderism academic censorship and
so on dr. Greger is the author of a
wonderful book called Galileo's middle
finger heretics activists and one
scholars search for justice as we'll
talk about in the podcast
Galileo's actual honest to goodness
finger is on display in a museum in
Florence you can go see it well worth it
at the Galileo Museum well everyone else
just look at the art you can go see the
Galileo relics there but it's also a
symbol Galileo was an ornery kind of
person who fought for both truth and for
justice he didn't back down under
political pressure and that's what we'll
be talking about today will be talk
talking about the various ways in which
you can try to get to the truth you can
try to get to justice and even though we
would like to think that the ultimate
goal of truth and justice coincides that
the boast just world is one in which
we're also telling the truth
it can sometimes happen that the road to
truth and the road to justice don't
always run on parallel tracks it's a
fascinating story no matter what your
actual substantive beliefs are about any
of the controversies the goal of trying
to be a good intellectual an honest
scholar finding out the truth about the
world while also being an activist in
the sense of trying to make the world a
better place is one that we can all
strive to uphold so let's go
[Music]
Alice Trager welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks Sean so you were in the
news recently even the news a lot okay
but there was a recent episode there was
a story in the New York Times by Barry
Weiss about something called the
intellectual dark web and it was
accompanied with moody photographs of
the members of this dark web all of whom
are it was hard exactly to figure out
what the commonalities were but there
was something about saying forbidden
scary truths in a certain set of venues
that might not be the most obvious
intellectually common ones and you were
invited to be part of this article and
part of the dark web and after some
consideration you declined do you let
your picture get taken if I understand
the fan you asked not to be included in
the article and you wrote a little piece
in The Chronicle of Higher Education
about that so can you explain just a
little bit what your thoughts were on
that maybe that will lead us into the
bigger picture here yeah I'm not sure I
can explain the dark web because I mean
when I know the dark web as is you know
the other dark web right the place where
nefarious things happen off off the
visible Internet but the intellectual
dark web as I understand it is supposed
to be some sort of connected group of
people who say things that in particular
piss off progressives as far as I can
tell and I've certainly said things that
have pissed off some progressives but
the reason I asked to get out of this
article profile was because it struck me
as increasingly silly the more I thought
about it the fellow who came out to take
my picture and have you seen these
pictures I think moody is a good way to
describe it they were all done exactly
at a particular moment with relation to
sunset and when the photographer called
me and told me like that's how it was
gonna be and we needed to be outside at
a very particular time because it was
gonna be this very particular moment at
sunset I was like fine I mean this guy
is a Pulitzer Prize winning photographer
his photographs are amazing so you know
whatever I mean I know for features they
sometimes do particular types of photos
but
then having gone through that and talked
to him I became increasingly war I mean
I was already worried before that
because I kept saying to Barry I I don't
know what this is sexual dark web is and
I don't even know of half the people
you're talking about so she would name
names like I'm supposed to know who
these people are and it's not that
they're not important or famous I just
don't spend a lot of time making a point
of connecting with you know big names
and so I like connecting with ordinary
people and smart people especially and
so it just struck me as something that I
had no idea what she was talking about
and then this photo struck me as
something where I felt kind of silly
doing it I was very nervous I remember
right after the photographer left I said
to my husband I got to get out of this
because I just don't think I'm meant to
be in this and I said I think I'm going
to feel silly if I'm part of a group
that I don't even know who half these
people are and I certainly don't have a
good sense of what makes us a category
and then you know the piece came out and
I was rather relieved that I wasn't in
it because as far as I could tell there
didn't seem to be any logical
categorization in which I belonged there
are people in that group that I really
respect I mean people like Brett
Weinstein and Heather Haig who are you
know academics in exile which they say
so am i although I I don't know we all
chosen at some level to be out of
academia at the moment but you know that
I really respect the two of them and the
work that they do and all of that but I
couldn't figure out otherwise what I was
supposed to have in common with these
other people other than Barry's
interests seemed to be a lot about the
idea that those of us in this alleged
group sometimes say things like yes sex
does matter in rape sometimes it's not
just about power it may also be about
sex for some in some circumstances for
the for the rapist that's not to say
it's a good thing it's just to say
talking about it as simply as power
doesn't really make sense of some of
what we see and we say things like there
are some inborn sex differences on
average or we say things like evolution
matters you know these are supposedly
things
are you're not allowed to say only we
are all saying them so what's the claim
that you're not supposed to say these
things is it the case that people push
back yeah sure my mail just got
delivered that's what that concourse you
know is it the case that we're not
supposed to you know that we say these
things that people push back yeah
certainly people push back but I think
people have been pushing back at things
I've been saying for 30 years that's
nothing new social media makes it more
intense and it catches fire faster but
just by virtue of irritating people I
don't think makes one special as an
intellectual I certainly had no trouble
hearing people say that biological
differences do matter it's not exactly a
completely silenced point of view out
there in the world not at all I mean I
it you know it may be the case that
among a certain set of progressives
saying biology matters is verboten but
you know within a large segment of
academia people are researching it and
we talk about it and we talk about how
do we think about that in terms of how
we approach equality and how do we think
about it in terms of how we support
people so I don't think that that's
really something you're not allowed to
say I really like the thing in your
chronicle article you pinpointed this
idea that the goal should not be to piss
the right people off right that's it's a
tempting thing and I think that it
speaks to the larger trajectory of your
career trying to balance a back and
forth between saying true things and
resisting kind of being funneled down to
an obvious comfortable spot right and
thinking that you're an oppressed
minority saying uncomfortable truths
that's a slightly flattering way to
think about yourself that is indeed very
tempting yeah I think it also it becomes
an easy way to get out of responsibility
and by that I mean you know if I get to
say oh I'm so oppressed and
misunderstood I'm sort of not having to
be responsible to the fact that maybe
what I've said really is very
threatening to somebody and maybe what
I'm saying really is disruptive to their
worldview potentially dangerous for them
so I don't like that way of thinking
about it in part because I think it's
really important that those of us who
say things that are politically
intense take responsibility for that and
address the challenges and the questions
that arise from that and that that
definitely started it bothered me about
the approach was like oh you piss people
off therefore your magic magic right
yeah yeah they said yeah it's it's a
like I said it's a it's a comfortable
place to be for a certain kind of
personality but it's not exactly
supposed to be what intellectuals or
scholars say I'm bummed I never got to
see my picture you didn't get a copy of
your picture come on well Barry said
she's gonna send it to me and then I
published that piece in The Chronicle
and she's not talking to me so I think
I'm never gonna get to see my picture
it's gonna be the famous playing card
nobody ever got to see and someday it'll
be worth a million dollars don't you
think you should do a parody of it just
standing out in the field with your
boots on buddy
right like taking on an iPhone you could
I think that's a beer do that so and I'm
suspecting that when you started off the
academic path and you're as a graduate
student as a historian you didn't
suspect that this is how your career
trajectory would go is that safe to say
I guess I didn't know where it was gonna
go I mean the thing is I dropped out of
college right so I never really expected
to go to graduate school I never
expected to become an academic so I
never when I was becoming an academic I
didn't have a firm sense of what that
was going to mean for my future and I
don't mean that I didn't know what it
involved I didn't know what it involved
but I also know my husband jokes that I
changed careers every 2pi years so point
two yeah that's right it's tau all right
ciao
that's right yeah every tell you that's
good so you can so I you can write if to
a whole nother audience by saying it
that I changed careers every two years
so I I was a very high achieving high
school student and I was very burned-out
and I said to my parents you know I
should not go to school right now I'm
too burned out and back then there was
no such thing called a gap year so I
couldn't say I need a gap year it wasn't
anything it was just calling it was
being a college student dropout right so
my parents begged me to go to school
which I did for a year I went to
Georgetown University for a year and I
was still totally burned out so I
dropped out and I became a mortgage
broker for five years on Long Island's
and I only you know like finished my
degree because I was getting tired of
mortgage brokering and I thought maybe
I'd go into real estate law so I
finished my degree at the state
university down the street and my my
advisor told me about graduate school
and it sounded really great like you
could you could read and people would
pay you to read that's not I was also in
therapy and my therapist declared me
cured and he was like get out of New
York so that you don't relapse like get
out of here just leave leave your
boyfriend leave your cats leave your
parents leave everything so I thought
well going to graduate school is a good
way to leave everybody so I did that and
the truth is my graduate department lost
my application and they admitted me out
of embarrassment so a person hit by an
accident and but I was good at it and I
also worked really hard because I was
used to working full time and going to
school full time so I was like a really
hard worker and so when I got to
graduate school and everybody else had
gone a normal path they were used to
being kind of frankly lazy right because
they were used to sitting around and
doing nothing but school and so I like
whipped through graduate school and
graduated in record time for my
department and you know went on and got
an academic job and everything but I
guess I always I to think you know well
this is the direction my career will go
my yeah I don't know I had a sense of
like I I should know what I'm doing next
in order to pay the rent and that's what
I've always done and then when I had a
kid in the year 2000 I realized I really
liked him and I really enjoyed being
with him he was very interesting he was
much more interesting than I expected
having a child would be and so I gave up
tenure in 2004 to be with my son more
and also to do more mainstream writing
and do more activism of the type I was
doing which was for patient rights in
the field of intersex which is when some
people are born with
not the standard mail or standard female
anatomy so I dropped out of tenured life
and I took a part-time job at
Northwestern long distance and so I I've
never really had write an organized life
around the standard systems just because
I get I get I guess I get bored easily
and so I stick with things my husband's
right around six years as long as I
stick with things except with him so huh
so I you know so the idea that like I'm
now I'm in something intellectual
darkweb I'm just like what do you think
it just makes me as weird so but you did
start there was a point at which in grad
school you were gonna be historian and a
fairly conventional way and no I was
gonna be a philosopher no I was gonna be
a philosopher I'm sorry the department I
was in was history and philosophy of
science and I went to graduate school
thinking I do philosophy of science but
I didn't like the kind of philosophy of
science being done at my program which
was this very intense theoretical type
of philosophy and so I switched over to
doing history and I really liked it I
really liked the concreteness of history
and I really liked the detective work of
history so I then I became a historian
but I didn't set out to graduate school
I really went to Creighton just a couple
to get out of work but I became then a
historian yeah and now I'm a historian
except now I'm a journalist because I
gave up doing academic life a couple
years ago so but even as a historian
it's not like you were studying shipping
routes he decided to study hermaphrodite
um in the nineteenth century is that
about right
yes because I was I was an mo feminist
and I was interested in the question of
how medicine and science coped with
biological blurriness when they were
insisting that there were only two sexes
so in the 19th century so the late 1800s
in particular there was this big
political movement that had begun among
women for their rights so that was the
early part of feminism and there was
also a movement among people we now
would call gay and lesbian people to
demand their rights and so these were
people who were challenging gender norms
very strongly and I was curious too
what doctors did when they were faced
with the fact that biology is blurry
because all their claims about gender
were that there's only two sexes and
there's no in between and in fact there
is in between so I was curious about
that so I started publishing on what had
happened in the late 19th century and
then people who were intersex living
then which was the mid-1990s started
contacting me and asking me to look at
what was going on today in the medical
system and to help them change the
medical system so then I got into
contemporary intersex treatment and that
led me into bioethics by accident so
some people think I'm a bioethicists but
I'm not really I'm really a historian
who does patient advocacy work sometimes
right and it's so the whole idea of
intersex is is fascinating I think for
me the best way to get into it is you
you have a page on your blog about the
question can a person be born with two
sets of genitals with one male and one
female set of genitals and you have a
very definitive statement about this no
but you can absolutely be born with
parts of both sexes so males and females
start off with all the same parts and if
you have a high level of androgens and
you're sensitive to that so that's a
kind of masculinizing hormone you'll go
the male route and a low level typically
you'll go the female route but it turns
out there's like a hundred different
ways besides that that can go in between
or can mix things up the reason you
can't have both sets of genitals is
because people are only born with one
set of parts so they'll either go left
or right or in-between or they'll be
mixed up in terms of the types but you
can't have genitals of both types unless
what you mean is can you have a vaginal
opening with a penis yes you can have
that but you can't have say a penis and
a clitoris because they're the same
organ and development and you can at the
labia minora majora and the scrotum
because they're the same organ and
development so they're going to go one
way or another or in between so people
tend to have this sort of weird
imagination that there's like you could
be completely male and completely female
you can't you only have one set of parts
so you can go one way or another or
blend them up yeah I think that this is
just an underappreciated fact about
human anatomy and development but it
makes perfect sense from an evolutionary
point of view you know evolution you
is what it has and tries to solve
problems in a relatively simple way but
the fact that the male and female
genitalia sex organs are two different
versions of what starts out as the same
thing and that the male scrotum is just
the female lobby uh that developed in a
different way that's an amazing fact I
think that is not very well understood
no that's right and there are some nice
animations now online that show genital
development and fetuses that shows you
can sort of slide a thing back and forth
and see what does it look like it
develops his female or as male or
in-between and this is stuff I didn't
know certainly when I went to graduate
school it was stuff I only found out
pretty much by accident and then I was
fascinated to learn like well why have I
not heard about this because this seems
really interesting and really kind of
important to know about sex development
and I realized well that's because the
medical system had suppressed it for
generations and kept the knowledge from
us because of the idea that this was
disruptive frankly to the social order
and that telling people about it was
just going to confuse people and create
a kind of discomfort which it does it
often does create or discomfort for
people and this fact helps explain why
there is this idea this concept of
intersex intersexuality and you already
alluded to the fact that in addition to
simply having XX or XY chromosomes by
the way that's not the only
possibilities right there's more
complicated things you can have but
there's also more to it than that
there's how these things get expressed
because of the hormones that you have
and the hormones you're sensitive to and
how they develop over time so as you say
there's all sorts of different specific
ways in which you can be something other
than the standard stereotypical male or
female there's also randomness in the
process so just like you can be born
missing a finger you can be born missing
a penis and have everything else in
terms of male development so there's
there's lots of variation in the system
and you're right evolution this makes
sense in terms of evolution because sex
development is a key part of evolution
that's how we mix up our genes and so
sex turns out to be very important in
terms of evolution and whenever
anything's important turn in terms of
evolution and there's going to be a
complex developmental process and
there's going to be variation and that's
where you get these variations and
variation happens through randomness but
it it also happens sometimes because of
genetic conditions running in families
so there are at least thirty something
different ways you can develop in terms
of sex and that far more than that if
you count them a different way but
there's plenty of different ways you can
develop in terms of sex development and
I know you've written on the question
which is extraordinarily important in
certain circles but what about when we
have the Olympics and we have men's
sports and women's four it's how do we
decide what is the right criterion for
dividing up people according to that
classification it's really hard to
figure out the answer to that and the
answer to that depends on what you're
trying to achieve so if what you're
trying to achieve is a sort of mythical
level playing field then you're going to
be stuck and the reason you're gonna be
stuck is because humans vary a
tremendous amount and if you start
making the decision well in terms of sex
we're gonna sort of draw the line right
here you've got to justify why you're
drawing the line right there and what
the Olympic Committee would say is that
you know women people playing as women
can't have too high a level of antigens
because it gives them an unfair
advantage the thing is women naturally
make androgens so I think I'm a typical
female based on what I know about my own
biology I've never had my chromosomes
checked but I'm pretty sure I'm typical
female and I'm making androgens right
now in my adrenal glands in the back of
my body just like other women and I'm
also making some androgens in my ovaries
right now because that's where we make
them males meanwhile make estrogen and
they're in their testes so all the sex
hormones we're all making all of them
it's just men males make more of them
than the average female will make and so
to make the claim well we're gonna cut
off where it's supposedly unfair for a
female to have is a difficult argument
to make because we're making them so why
should we be told we're not allowed to
have a certain high level of them we
don't do that when it comes for example
to people's height we don't say you're
too tall to play basketball we don't say
to people you know in terms of their
ability to process oxygen well you were
born with a genetic advantage so you're
not allowed to use that genetic
advantage you're not allowed to play no
we
say look if you're born with it you're
allowed to play with it but where women
are concerned where intersex gets
involved that's where the Olympic
Committee tries to cut things off and it
becomes very difficult to do that my own
feeling is and I've written about this
most recently for the New York Times
basically the rules they've come up with
are pretty absurd because they declare
certain sex hormones to be sort of the
property of men even though women do
make them and then they also have a
system where they're setting up a system
that has to measure something they can't
really yet be measured so they're trying
to measure not only do you make these
hormones but do they affect you and we
don't have a good system for
understanding to what degree they're
affecting one's tissues and the
effectiveness of hormones on our tissues
varies according to people so it's kind
of a crazy system it doesn't they may
have the data to show that testosterone
improves performance in certain events
and they do have that data and I believe
that data
I believe testosterone absolutely gives
you an advantage in certain events
certain running events but they then
leap to a policy that I think is very
hard to justify and that's where they
keep falling down on their faces and
when I advise the Olympic Committee in I
think it was 2012 I was there and in
Switzerland basically what I said to
them is you're making the same mistake
that the Olympic Committee has made over
and over again every time it's tried to
adjudicate sex according to biology and
you're running up against the problem
where biology is complicated and genders
come in two categories for purposes of
the Olympics why don't you just admit
you've got to gender categories and stop
trying to police the biology but the
answer is they're afraid the Chinese
will raise their sons as daughters and
they're afraid that they'll have boys
playing as girls in the Olympics I mean
it's almost as if nature in the natural
world is very complicated and fluid and
full of all kinds of crazy things but we
human beings really like to impose on
nature these orderly categories and then
we get upset when nature does not
conform to that order we want to impose
on it
we certainly do and we get even more
upset if money's involved the Olympics
is concerned
our winners a crapload there's a
crapload of money involved so there's a
lot of a lot of money at stake in terms
of these decisions and that's part of
what's going on
what cracked me up is when I went to
that meeting that was an advisory
meeting they had a series of advisory
meetings and I was one of many people
that they invited to comment and
critique and have a conversation about
this but what became clear to me is that
it was mostly men making decisions about
women's sports and I was curious what
would happen if women were actually in
charge of women's sports and what
decision women would make and I suspect
it would be different because I suspect
women who have been athletes are very
sensitive to the idea of having your
body your body policed that's happened
to them over and over and over again and
I think they would have more sympathy
for the people getting caught in that
policing but I don't know because right
now men are largely in charge of women's
sports at that level and this policing
in some sense in a different context is
what led you to go on the journey from
being a historian to an activist because
you stumbled across the fact that
surgeons were policing maleness and
femaleness of infants as soon as they
were born they would notice that someone
was intersex one way or the other and
try to fix them and number one that was
historically interesting because it
started happening I guess in the 1900s
but you'll tell me but then it was still
happening even today yeah we started to
see the beginnings of that approach in
the eighteen hundred's the late 1800s
but when surgery got better then
surgeons got more aggressive and part of
what has occurred is the idea that
anybody who's left sexually in between
will grow up to be miserable and and
depressed and rejected and therefore
they will kill themselves and so you
have to fix every baby to look closer to
a standard male or standard female type
now intersex by the way sometimes occurs
where on the outside of the body you
look very clearly like one sex but on
the inside you have the organs of the
other so when we're talking about the
early intersex interventions done by
surgeons we're talking about cases where
there's visible sex anomalies on the
outside of the body
and in those cases still today what
happens is most surgeons say well you
don't want to leave a kid in
Queen and therefore we should either
surgically make this child look more
male or more more female in many cases
that means female because surgeons have
a sort of high standard when it comes to
what a male should look like and a
rather low standard male surgeons
largely largely male surgeons they they
think penises are very fancy organs and
vaginas are just old and vaginas are not
just holes they're actually very fancy
organs the vaginal tube the thing that
is the vagina the the tube that goes
from the opening on the outside up to
the uterus is actually a very fancy
organ but they don't treat it as such
they treat it as something that can be
replicated by creating a hole basically
a hole that is you know medically safe
hole so that that started happening in
earnest starting in the 1950s and
there's an entire their generations now
if people who grew up that way who were
lied to about their medical history who
have surgical problems resulting from
what happened some of whom had their
fertility taken away from them because
any chance of fertility was removed in
those sex assignment process and those
people became activists many of them
became activists in the intersex rights
movement starting especially in the
1990s and it was a pretty active
movement at the point at which I was
contacted by some of those people and I
joined the movement as well because I
could see that what they were describing
was absolutely in the medical literature
and it was going on and to me it was
really disturbing to see what was going
on it wasn't that the doctors had bad
intentions they really wanted what was
best for these kids but they had a very
narrow idea of what was possible and
they had very bad science extremely bad
science when it came to following up
whether or not this was actually working
and did you is it safe to say that you
and your friends and have actually had
an effect on the practice that surgeons
now were a little bit more aware of
what's going on there certainly much
more aware whether or not we have
changed the practices an open question
I'm afraid we haven't changed it nearly
enough what has changed is now doctors
say well it's the parents decision and
so the parents are kind of pressured in
many cases to make this decision and are
told you know well everybody's fine if
you just do what we tell you and parents
tend to follow what their pediatricians
tell them to do so there are a bunch of
clinicians now that I know that
reformists who strongly feel as I do
that you can raise kids as boys or girls
but leave their bodies intact if there's
no medical emergency let them decide for
themselves later whether or not they
want to take the risk of changing
anything about their body let them have
bodily autonomy and for those clinicians
they find parents are comfortable with
their with what they're recommending and
I think that's because they're in those
circumstances their pediatricians are
telling them it's okay and to wait and
it's okay to let this child decide for
him or herself how do they want to
handle their body so for some places
it's better but in a lot of places it's
the same old system it's just now the
parents are blamed for the decision
making rather than the surgeons taking
responsibility for the decision-making
and what was it like for you sort of
lifestyle wise and intellectually to
become an activist while you were also
being an active scholar and a professor
ah
well since I was in the humanities it
wasn't that hard because unfortunately
the humanities is largely gone in the
direction of doing politics I didn't
think of myself as being in the what I
see often as the lazy versions of that
within the humanities and academia in
some circumstances but for me it was
exhausting mostly because I was helping
to run a national and international
movement from my house and at the same
time doing a full-time academic career
which involved publishing in
peer-reviewed journals which I liked
doing but it was you know that's intense
work doing the kinds of teaching that
was intensive teaching because I really
liked teaching and also doing service
work so I was doing full-time academic
work and also basically full-time
helping to run the intersect Society
North America's cause and at the same
and then I had a kid on top of it all
and that that just became untenable in
terms of the lifestyle so when I made a
list of what I enjoyed doing the things
I didn't enjoy doing involve my academic
job so I gave that up and switch
switched what I was doing at that point
and then you got involved in I guess a
related but different controversy about
transgenderism which is different let's
just get all the terminology on the
table here
there's a lot going on when we talk
about sex and how sex plays out in the
world they're sort of at the very least
our biological sex our gender identity
how we think of ourselves as male or
female according to the standards of the
world we live in our gender expression
right how what clothes we wear our
mannerisms and so forth
and our sexual orientation who we are
attracted to and all of these things are
going on at once and the intersex is
about more or less our biological sex as
it were and transgenderism more about
our gender identity is that correct did
I get that right yes congratulations all
right well I would just mention that
before I got into this controversy over
transgenderism I expanded my work
outward and looked at what else was
happening to children born with Norman
geing bodies so I looked at things like
conjoined twins and the way they were
treated in society and in medicine and I
looked at people with dwarfism people
with giantism and those sorts of things
in the book I did then on that topic was
called one of us can join twins in the
future of normal and that that's a very
it was published by Harvard but it's
it's a very readable book basically
designed to be used for freshmen
undergraduates restoratives getting into
this question of what do our bodies have
to do with who we are and when should we
change our bodies and when should we
hold back and think about changing
society instead so yes so intersex is
about how our bodies are that when we're
born and transgenderism or gender is
about how we feel about ourselves so I
often tell people that intersex people
and transgender people had this opposite
problems but for the same core reason
historically so intersex people were
getting sex change operations they
didn't ask for and transgender people
historically had a hard time getting sex
change operations they did want but they
were both suffering for the same reason
which was a patriarchal patriarchal
medical system that said we get to
decide what you'll look like and we'll
get to decide what sex you are so that's
finally changing and it certainly
changed a lot more on the transgender
side and today is fortunately much
easier for people who may benefit from
hormonal changes and from surgical
changes to go ahead and elect those for
themselves and that's a very positive
development
we're actually swinging very far in that
direction and now we're starting to see
some problems with sending people down
that route without actually doing an
adequate workup to see if that's really
what's going to help them in terms of
their own personal situations but it's
certainly better than it used to be when
it was very very difficult for people to
get access to legal sex change or gender
change and social gender change and then
also surgical changes to their bodies to
match the way that they felt and a
similar issue comes up with the
conjoined twins right there was this
surgical idea that it would help them to
separate them that would make them more
normal we have categories we have a view
of what a person should be like and that
view doesn't have another person
attached to them and you found that in
fact lots of conjoined twins would
prefer just to remain conjoined if
they're healthy in that condition yeah I
was shocked by that when I came to the
subject of conjoined twins I fully
expected that anybody who could be
separated would elect to do so that
nobody would be doing okay conjoined and
instead when I looked historically at
all the cases I could find there's not
as many of them as other types of
variations in the world so that was a
little bit easier when I looked at that
what I found was that there was only one
single case in history where conjoined
twins old enough to do so for themselves
chose separation and both of them died
from it and that historically over time
and throughout different cultures
conjoined twins said the same thing if
they grew up together they said I know
this isn't normal for me for the rest of
the world but this is normal for us and
I wouldn't want to live the way you live
so what was really surprising to me was
they consistently said the way we live
is superior to the way you live because
you must get lonely and you don't have
anybody with you all the time and we
have somebody with us all the time so
the thing that we see as a terrible
disadvantage is seen by them to be a
terrible a huge advantage and when I
thought about it I realized that
shouldn't have surprised me so much
because so speaking for example if
somebody is born female and has grown up
as a
girl and a woman I know that I'm
discriminated against in terms of wages
in terms of political representation I'm
much more likely to be sexually
assaulted than a male is you know all of
these things but my solution to that is
not well I wish I was a man right even
though I know that that would eliminate
the discrimination I experienced so
conjoined twins were saying basically
the same thing they were saying I know
I'm subject to a lot of discrimination
but I don't think I'm the problem I
think the problem is the discrimination
system so as I began to look at that and
then look at what the surgeries did to
people in some circumstances separation
surgeries are very simple they're
practically outpatient surgeries in some
cases and in some cases they're just a
little bit complicated but not a big
deal but in many of the cases we hear
about their enormous ly complicated and
they leave people really damaged if
they're joined at the head they leave
them brain damaged if they're joined se
sharing a body in the middle part
they're left without organs it often
disrupts their sexual sensation and
function it'll disrupt their ability to
have normal bowel movements to have
urinary function
they'll have problems with pulmonary
function in some cases if what we're
doing is separating the upper part of
the body so really it's not the case
that there's it's simple that they're
always better off if you separate them
and so I started to question that and
that that became an interesting period
of my life because I ended up talking to
surgeons who were doing conjoined twin
separations who started to hear of my
work and read my work and began to ask
the question am I really helping which I
really appreciate it that they would ask
that question you know am I really
helping not all of them were thoughtful
I remember what I was talking to it
could hear him opening his mail in the
background well we're having this
discussion about what's gonna separate
these two boys who were joined at the
head who I was sure he was gonna kill so
that not all of them were so sensitive
and sensible but many of them were it's
very sobering how deeply ingrained this
idea is that we want other people to
become normal by our lights right rather
than asking them what they want it's
this there's kind of a relationship it's
a little bit different but everyone
grows old right and people get sent to
assisted care facilities senior centers
and whatever and there's studies have
shown that the elderly really would like
to have much more autonomy than we give
them well we try to give them as safety
right the the caregivers or whatever try
to protect them and they tend to want to
do risky things that give them a feeling
of freedom but we don't want to let them
I'm not it's not exactly the same set of
issues but it's the same human desire to
sort of control other people's lives and
make them normal by our own standards we
do the same thing with people with
disabilities and we do the same thing
with children and it's a real problem
because in all those circumstances you
think you're helping but if you actually
bother to listen to the people whose
lives you're limiting they often do not
feel that you're helping they feel that
you are oppressing them so I think it is
something that we have to think about
much more carefully certainly for
example you know there are circumstances
of course where people are in nursing
care facilities who still want to have
sex and we have the attitude well that
part of your life is over well why the
heck should that part of your life be
over right and for adults with
disabilities including cognitive
disabilities many of them do still want
to have access to sex or access to going
out and having a good time and so the
Independent Living movement within the
disability rights community has been
very positive in that way but there's
been a lot of defunding of a lot of
systems that allow independent living
and certainly for children we
infantilized our children for a very
very long time so compared to other
nations the United States for example
has much higher drinking ages is slower
to permit things like control of your
own medical decision-making many places
you could be younger and make decisions
about your own medical care before you
can in the United States age of consent
is lower in terms of many other places
so there are many ways in which I think
we just infantilized our children in
this country in ways that do not empower
them and also don't really protect them
because the fact is 15 and 16 and 17
year olds will do what they will do
anyway
and claiming well there's that reality
deal with yes/no so my own feeling is
that it's it's terribly important to
empower your kids I did I mean more
recently I wrote a book about talking to
your kids about sex because a few years
ago my son invited me to his sex ed
class where they were teaching
abstinence which he knows drives me up
the wall and I ended up live tweeting it
which became viral so then I was asked
to write a book about talking to kids
about sex so that's a book called the
talk and in there I just sort of modeled
what I've done in my own parenting which
is trying to take seriously children as
real people in the world and to address
their actual questions with real answers
not not mamby-pamby around stuff tell
them the truth yeah it's kind of amazing
to be sex and death to a very
fundamental features of human life and
yet two of the things that at least out
there socially we're afraid to talk
about as grown-ups right well joke will
sort of nervously titter about this or
that and we'll get a laugh but the idea
of just sort of talking about it as a
real thing that's going to happen and
let's be honest about it and even with
children or the elderly is just
remarkably hard for the society to catch
on to it is and and this leads sort of
naturally into the conversation of how I
got in trouble by doing doing the
history that controversy over
transgenderism part of what I was doing
was I was taking seriously the idea that
transgenderism also implicates issues of
sexuality and for many years people in
the transgender rights movement
understandably kind of desexualized
transgenderism made it all about gender
never about sex even though one of the
things that often happens for people who
are transgender is they change their
genitals so it has something to do with
sex right it has something to do with
self-presentation and genital feeling
and how you want to interact in terms of
your sexual encounters but a lot of the
mainstream doesn't want to talk about
sex just as they don't want to talk
about death and so to push for
transgender rights it became necessary
to sort of desexualize it just like when
gay and lesbian people were actively
working on marriage equality
they often stopped talking about
sexuality they talked about adopting
children and about cooking dinner
together and watching TV together but
nobody was mentoring what's happening in
terms of sex because the straight
population is more comfortable with the
idea that we're not going to talk about
sex and so it's easier to access your
rights in that way and so there's
controversy that I got into had to do
with one particular area of sexuality
studies around transgender we was
looking at transgender women who
transitioned because of sexual
orientation issues and this was
extremely dicey a thing to talk about
politically and so the researchers that
I was tracking the history of got
attacked for talking about this and then
I became attacked as well for having
tracked out what happened to those
researchers when they crossed the line
so in particular the idea that at least
some people who want to transition from
male to female do so because they find
it sexually arousing or a sexually
interesting or that's that's part of
their motivation not and not all people
and that's not the only motivation but
at least it's there right that for some
people transition isn't just about
gender identity it's also about sexual
orientation and I don't think that
should be that surprising because I
think for many of us our sexual
orientations are connected to our gender
identities so when I'm having sex as a
woman I think I'm doing it as a woman
I've paused to think about it sometimes
because I'm interested intellectually in
this question but I think for a lot of
us when our gender feelings become most
vivid is actually when we're having sex
so I don't think there's anything
unusual in that a transgender person
might have that interaction going for
themselves as well in terms of their
orientation and their gender identity
but to talk about that is was to be seen
as going back to a really nasty old
conversation about transgenderism that
saw it merely as a fetish and merely as
a kink and merely as something that was
sort of something perverted and
inappropriate and that's not what these
researchers were saying they were saying
no this is actually a legitimate way to
be transgender and there's and they
would say there's actually no reason to
deny people access to transition
because of this is just sometimes
sexuality is part of the equation that's
not just a lot of interesting material
for your tinder profile some of the
researchers said these things in ways
that were sort of cold or even outright
offense I rated lis offensive and so
that's how they got in trouble but what
happened to one of them Michael Bailey
is when I traced in the book Galileo's
middle finger and that was that he was
beset upon by a group of transgender
activists who basically made up a whole
bunch of lies about him and when I came
to that part of my research and I
decided to look into this because I knew
people on both sides of this controversy
was rather curious to know what really
had happened I really like questions
were like I've been told one thing and
everything else seems to be true so I
looked into that for about a year looked
at a thousand sources and interviewed
about a hundred people and at the end of
it what I found was that the charges
about Bailey were simply made-up and
that the people who had made them
probably knew that these were false
charges but I'd basically tried to just
shut him up because they didn't want his
view of transgenderism getting out into
the popular realm so when I did that
they came after me and that was very
very very unpleasant and that was in the
round 2008 when it was easier because of
Google's algorithms to take over a
person's identity and that's what
occurred and actually I'll tell you so
literally yesterday I was going to a
local coffee shop that I go to a lot and
the woman who owns it came up to me and
said Alice I was wondering if we could
have coffee sometime soon and I said
yeah sure of course would be happy to
copy with you and she said to me because
people are telling me that you hate
transgender people and I was like oh my
god and this was this trace back all the
way to that stuff and this claim that's
out there that I somehow hate
transgender people even though I've a
dated for transgender rights in sports
I've worked on national projects to
improve the care the medical care of
people who are transgender I mean but
but what happens is if people want to
defame you in the social media world as
it exists today it can happen pretty
easily and then it takes on a life of
its own and people cannot figure out
what's true about you so it's and what
can I do right there's a whole bunch of
stuff out there online
that's simply not true and there's
nothing I can do about it and they
showed up on your webpage you had the
very vivid story of what do you recently
gave a talk at Wellesley was it
illicit end yes certain opinions about
you have been shared and people can look
protests and as far as you could tell
they were protesting a completely
different person than you would think of
yourself which is a very surreal thing
when you've spent your whole life
studying the relationship between
anatomy and identity and you're standing
there your bodily standing there right
in your own flesh and people are yelling
at you about an identity that they swear
is yours that you don't recognize at all
it's a very strange experience and in
the picture I put up of that moment
where I face these hundred something
people young people protesting me only
protesting a version of me I don't
recognize I'm just standing there
listening to them and thinking to myself
you know like how do you even begin to
get a foothold here because at the end
of the day their politics and my
politics I think exactly a line but they
think I'm the enemy so that's what I
thought that's why I felt very strongly
when reading Galileo's middle finger
this sense of heartbreak in some sense
because you and the people who are
coming to attack you in some sense want
what is best for transgender people
neither of you are trying to shut them
down or laugh let them live their lives
but there is a mismatch because you're
trying to be an intellectual be a
scholar trying to say what is the truth
about the situation as best we
understand it right now and of course
it's always subject to change if more
studies come along or whatever and they
have a certain strategy for winning a
fight for justice that they think that
this particular point of view that you
say might be right gets in the way of
and it's it's almost an impossible
dilemma to address in some sensible way
it is and I've I mean I've largely given
up on that front and have talked to
other people who unfortunately have done
the same you know the good news is
there's a lot of really fine clinicians
now who are working on changing the
system within medicine for transgender
issues there are a lot of terrific
lawyers working on the legal and social
shoes so there are a lot of people in
politics changing the laws so there's
real progress happening and that's why I
don't feel like I'm needed too much but
it is nevertheless disappointing that we
can't have conversations that go beyond
sort of you know screaming around about
who is a bigot and who is not a bigot
and it just it feels very frustrating
but that's the whole social media
experience on everything these days so
if this this area's not special in that
way it's just it's just a little
disconcerting when somebody you've known
for years you know has heard that your
your Nazi basically feels the need to
ask you are you not seeing you're like
well I'm gonna tell you I'm not a Nazi
but what's my proof right what is gonna
so he would say I know exactly right now
I saw yeah I brought a stack of my books
and I'm like I hate to give you a lot of
homework but I'm gonna give you what
I've actually written and would have
actually done and if you want to look at
it you can look at it so I gave her a
whole stack of stuff you know one said
this is what I've actually written and
actually said and you know some of it
does irritate some people but I think if
you read it you're not going to find any
evidence here that I as people have
claimed want to send intersex people to
the gas chambers or want to stop people
from transitioning who will benefit from
transition ie none of that is true
it's kind of this human desire to
categorize people like okay you're
either male or your female . you're
either an ally or you're an enemy . and
if you're an enemy you're the worst kind
of enemy that's all you could possibly
be you have it exactly right and I I've
always sucked at categories I mean look
at like what I study right I've always
been interested in people who don't fit
categories and in that sense I think
it's something I've always related to I
don't you know I was at the top of my
class in high school
I was not supposed to be a college
dropout you know I got tenure early I
was not supposed to give up tenure but
I'm not satisfied with the worlds
categories like I don't find it
interesting to live in those categories
so that's why the people I study often
are people who are challenging those
categories whether intentionally or
unintentionally through their bodies but
it does drive me crazy because I keep
running up against people who want to
say well are you X or you are you
I and I'm like I don't recognize that
set of categories like really you don't
think there's any other way to be in the
world so for example I mean I'm a I'm a
progressive but I run a non-profit he's
a non partisan newspaper now for East
Lansing Michigan which is where we live
and you know they're people want to say
to me like I don't understand it you're
progressive but like you're taking
developers seriously and my attitude is
why should I not be interested in the
thoughts and the actions of people who
are not like me right but it's very it's
very very frustrating but the thing
about these categories is that they are
in some sense there's a landscape of
where you can live intellectually and
gravity pulls us down to some certain
valleys and that's where the categories
live so this makes you literally
Sisyphus trying to constantly push the
ball back up the hill well and I hate to
sound like a you know anti-capitalist
because I'm not really anti-capitalist
but I will say money does matter here
again
so if you are online the way that people
will make money off of you is if you
feel strongly about categories so if
they can convince you that a particular
brand is absolutely the type of running
shoe that you want or the type of
underwear you want or the type of
politician you want or the type of law
you want whatever it is if they can
convince you that you have a particular
category that is the only category you
want they will figure out ways to
monetize that so when we look at places
that are conventional newspapers they
have largely become opinion pages
because opinion pages cause people to
click and clicking means that you can
sell ads so there is a strong bias in
our world today towards convincing
people to be narrow-minded being
broad-minded is not a good way to sell
products getting people to be
narrow-minded is a very good way to sell
products because they will narrow what
it is they're going to choose and
they'll pay more because there's not
very much in that category so they will
pay more to purchase within that
category and that's how we end up in the
situation we do politically in terms of
the
undermining of newspapers becoming pure
opinion pages that's how we got here and
it's it's really problematic so you know
if you go on YouTube and you click on
what you like on YouTube it'll draw you
down an ever-more sort of particular
path because that's when you end up with
the ads if you're if you're actually
pretty broad and you click on this and
that and you're not really interested in
number of views and you're just watching
whatever there's no money to be made off
of you but there's money to be made off
of you if we can convince you you are
really into X and you're not into Y so I
conclude from this that you are a rabid
anti-capitalist and you would like to
collectivise the farms and institute
five-year plans right that's just a
logical consequence of what you just
said no I mean it's I don't know how to
solve that problem other than trying to
convince people that living within
categories is actually not very
interesting or satisfying but that said
I will recognize I'm much more
comfortable with change and ambiguity
than most people are and so I think part
of what we have to do is think about how
can we cultivate a value of volatility
and ambiguity among our populace and
make them realize it doesn't have to be
scary but a lot of people are very
scared of ambiguity but they don't have
to be I think it's it is Gary I think it
you're not gonna get rid of the
scariness I think that the best you
could hope to do is to say embrace the
scariness of it all I think that's right
and there are limits to what we can
embrace and even when we have a bad in
the house every now that we get a bat in
the house right because you live in a
part of Michigan with big trees in our
neighborhood and that means we have a
lot of bats and every now and then we
get a bat in the house and there is this
other worldly sense of ambiguity that
there is some creature that will not
communicate with us that is in our space
and we have to figure out where the hell
it just went and get it out and that is
the moment which I realize I am not
comfortable with certain kinds of
ambiguity I am not comfortable when
there's another creature that
will not communicate with me that is in
my space it freaks me the hell out and
so ya know we all have our limits and
I'm not different from people that way I
mean I definitely have my limits in
terms of the ambiguity I can tolerate
well in there's one sentence in
Galileo's middle finger that I thought
really pinpointed for better for worse
the dilemma that is faced by people who
would like both truth and justice in the
world you say we didn't know of any
successful rights movement that wasn't
based on an essential eyes dared
identity even if it even if just
constructed in politically expedient
ways so that's kind of pinpointing the
difference between this anti category
live in fear that's the complexity and
the subtlety of the world intellectual
point of view and the idea that well we
want to make the world a better place we
want to improve things and maybe that
means bringing people under an umbrella
of a certain shared identity even if
it's not a completely perfect fit to the
how the world actually is ya know there
there are times when it's very useful to
do that I mean we do that as families
for example right the way we define who
is in the family or is not in the family
will depend on the immediate need of the
kin and will change the boundaries on
that as necessary we do that within our
own communities whether there's a if
there's a threat for example communities
may form that are not logically their
own communities but they'll form
temporarily in response to a threat so
certainly we all do that and the
challenge to me is how do we how do we
not make the borders of that so strong
that we can't be flexible and allow
change to occur when it's time for
change to occur again that can be really
difficult up to a couple days ago I was
a huge LeBron James fan because it
looked like he might join the
Philadelphia 76ers which is the best
basketball team in the world but now
he's joined the Lakers so I think he's a
terrible terrible person and he's the
enemy you know what can I do sorry he's
in the wrong tribe change which sport
you watch I don't know hell I can't do
that you're still in that category
oh yeah though I'm not very happily in
the in the category of crazy
Philadelphia 76ers fan who thinks
teams are morally failures but you
didn't stop you hadn't you didn't
despite the transgender controversy and
the emotional toll it must have taken
like I'm a conflict averse person I
don't think I could have stood up to
what you had to put up with but you've
managed to get into a couple of new
controversy since then there was the
Maria new controversy on left with say
it right dexamethasone stay ROI right
yes yeah that that related to the
intersex rights work so this is a
researcher physician who the short
version of it was that she was
convincing women at risk for having
daughters born with intersex genitals to
take a steroid when they were pregnant
with these fetuses and to try to prevent
the intersex development and the problem
with it was not only that this was
ending up affecting fetuses who could
not benefit because only seven out of
eight of the pregnancies identified
would actually involve a child of that
type the bigger problem was she was
telling the families that this had been
found safe for mother and child when in
fact she was at the same time getting
money from the National Institutes of
Health claiming that she needed to study
these families to see if it was safe or
effective so she was using the same
population she had brought in with a
sales pitch that it was safe to say how
I need grant money to see if this had
been safe and that was extremely
disturbing to me from an ethics point of
view and this was not some fringe figure
she's like the grand old lady of she's a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences she's a highly distinguished
pediatric endocrinologist one of the top
people in her field yeah so I tried to
get the government to intervene in that
case with a bunch of colleagues and that
failed the government doesn't function
very well and certified shocker shocker
and the government doesn't feel up to
you like it's supposed to protect you
exactly so that took a couple years off
my life both at the time and probably at
the end of my life it'll shave off a few
years I got into a fight with the Food
and Drug Administration with the
American Journal of bioethics and
the medical schools of Cornell and Mount
Sinai I have to tell you you know this
is this is another reason why I think if
we can go back to the beginning of our
conversation why I think I don't fit in
the intellectual dark web because a lot
of those people spend a lot of their
time sort of dealing with you know
hot-button controversy issues out in the
mainstream I dig my feet in a lot of the
time and take on small but I think
morally deeply important projects and
work on them for years and you know the
kinds of stuff I do is like hardcore
historical investigations I I take on
projects that literally take years at a
time in order to try to figure out what
happened and to try to bring some
justice and so I just don't think those
people are doing that you know they're
they're doing a different kind of
political pundit tree that doesn't
really I do a little bit of political
punditry but a lot of what I do is hard
core research in historical areas
involving science and medicine so a few
years ago Jon Brockman has these
collections these edge questions of the
year that he then collects into books
and he asks is he's a literary agent he
asks his stable of writers to write
something pithy and small in response to
some question and the question was what
have you changed your mind about and
I've changed my mind about a million
things most of them wouldn't be that
interesting so what I wrote up was being
a heretic is hard work
and I think as a yeah well being a good
heretic right being a heretic at all is
actually no work at no work whatsoever
and I think that when I was a college
student and I was first learning about
physics and so forth I had this romantic
idea of you know having some heterodox
view of mainstream physics and I was
going to overthrow it and you know
change the world and having a view that
is both correct and widely disparaged is
really hard they have to do a lot of
work it's easy to just be contrarian
it's hard to do the dirty work of
establishing the truth of something that
is not considered to be already pretty
obvious exactly and and that
I mean I also find that work really
satisfying because it babies could a
show that I was raised Catholic
it's very thankless and I really like
that about it because you're not doing
it for any kind of conventional reward
system you're really doing it cuz it's
it's hard core work to me it's like when
I you know when I go running and I'm not
a natural runner but when I go running
and I push myself really hard and
there's nobody with me and I'm not
tracking the run or anything I'm just
doing it because it's hard I really like
that and I think a lot of intellectuals
are like that where they really like a
difficult problem and they really want
to tackle it and that's where by the way
a lot of activists are very different
from intellectuals because I think a lot
of activists really want the easy way
out if they could flip a switch and get
what they wanted they would do it I
would never be interested in flipping a
switch if I didn't understand what was
behind the switch and what all the
implications are of switch flipping a
switch and can I think about the
unintended consequences you know can I
think through that and can I figure out
what the switch is really you know like
you I really I really want to you know
really want to get my feet into it but
that is it is really hard work well the
categories of activist intellectual are
hard to straddle equally right I think
that both are important it's important
to make the world a better place it's
important to find the truth and be
objective about it but one tends to have
a value that is more important and if
you're an intellectual if finding the
truth regardless of its consequences is
the most important thing to you then
that leads you to certain practices and
certain things that you're gonna
consider to be enjoyable and having a
good time and it might not be the same
as those who are juiced up by the
activist lifestyle by just changing the
world for the sake of changing the world
the world needs to be changed yeah I
think you're right we need both but
there there often feel very different
there are though I mean there are
pockets of places where people are
intellectuals and activists and those to
me are very exciting places for example
the ACLU at its best is a place that
joins intellectualism and activism
there's a lot of legal groups we're
really cool stuff happens with and
there's also some medical activist
groups for example some of the medical
groups around
trying to bring evidence-based clinical
practice into being so for example the
loan Institute that tries to look at
what we really know in terms of the data
and tries to avoid over intervention
over treatment in medicine and tries to
pull back and say you know we don't need
to over medicate we don't need to over
and send too many people in for
procedures that don't actually help
those kinds of places I think that join
that heavy intellectualism with a real
activist strategy of trying to improve
people's lives those are really exciting
places well you mentioned in The
Chronicle piece that despite the fact
that you are no longer strictly speaking
a professor you love the professorial
academia walking across the college
campus there it is a it's a space that
is kind of unique in our culture we're
trying to figure out hard questions and
answer them deeply is valued but
nevertheless you quit your job you had a
tenured faculty job so why don't you
tell us that story so after after I gave
up tenure I was working at Michigan
State University for where I got tenure
my friends at Northwestern's Medical
School in the program medical humanities
and bioethics offered me a long-distance
part-time job which I took I had a big
name by then and they were interested in
like having my company and having my
name and in exchange I would have their
name and it would all be lovely and I
was I loved my colleagues there and I
were ended up working there for 10 years
the job sort of swelled and set back
depending on what was needed in terms of
my home life because I was raising a kid
at home 200 miles from my job at the
same time so it you know it all depended
on like did I have a big speaking year
if I had a big speaking year I laid back
on the northwestern job etc etc so about
a year and a half before I ended up
giving up that job I was asked to edit
the annual magazine slash Journal of our
department which is a journal called
atrium and atrium published short
intense interesting pieces that were on
a particular theme for each issue so
these are medical humanities theme so we
had themes like power and the liminal
and good and evil I mean these are sort
of interesting themes within meadows
and we would invite people to submit
proposals in terms of what they wanted
to write and some people were physicians
or historians of Medicine or
philosophers or bioethicists or nurses
or patients whoever it was you could
submit and on the theme and we would
choose a certain number of them had
published them it's a very high gloss
beautiful production and we edited it
very carefully it was very well
respected it was subscribed to by 3,000
people and it was also read very widely
online for free so the year I was
invited to be the editor of it the theme
that the editor-in-chief chose was bad
girls which was perfect because it was
about gender it was about morality and
stuff I do
so I solicited we put together a call
for proposals as a group and sent it out
as we always did and people send me
about 33 different proposals and out of
that we could pick about 13 of them and
one of them I chose was a piece by and
cultural anthropologist named William
peace be EAC II at Syracuse University
and Bill piece was writing about his own
experience he does cultural anthropology
and disability studies and Bill was born
with a neurological condition that meant
when he was 18 years old he became
paralyzed from the waist down and he was
in a long-term rehabilitation facility
at that point and he was wondering about
his own sexuality this was in the late
1970s and you know it's the sexual
revolution he is a young man he wants to
have sex of course someday he wants to
be a father so he's asking his doctors
about this and none of them are really
willing to talk with him about it so he
talks about the fact that he's in this
institution where basically these men
were there for a very long time and they
got to know the nurses really well and
sometimes there were relationships that
blossomed between nurses and patients in
this circumstance because this was not
like a hospital wasn't like people you
just meet once and they're disappearing
these are people they knew for months
and years at a time and in his
circumstance he tells the story in this
piece that I published where one night
he was thinking he finally got bladder
control and he wet the bed again it was
very depressed and crying and he hits
the nurse call button and this nurse
that he had become very close friends
with comes and basically she reassured
him by giving him oral sex and he writes
about it as a moment of compassion
and a moment which really gave him hope
that he could go on to have a positive
sexual life it still makes me tear up
when I write about it cuz I think it's
it's one of those moments where somebody
really reaches out to you and meets you
where you are and sure enough you know
he did go on to have a good sex life he
ended up becoming a father he's had a
really good life and so he wrote this
piece for me and part of what he was
doing in this piece was asking the
question do we yet take care of the
sexual needs of people who are newly
disabled you know are we addressing this
at all and he didn't say which this
should be what should happen in
rehabilitation facilities in fact he
called it the Wild West period of
medicine and rehabilitation medicine
which it was it was a very crazy period
it's when infection control got good
enough that people were surviving at
levels they never had survived before
but what happened was after this was
published a few months after this was
published and a gun out with a bunch of
other intense articles frankly articles
about transgenderism in samoa and
articles about women who give birth
without a medical system I'm very you
know articles about abortion one of
which made me really uncomfortable and
I'm pro-choice you know like very
intense stuff as we always published my
Dean Eric Nielsen the medical school
northwestern saw the issue and saw bill
pieces article and flipped out and
apparently said that he was worried that
it would violate a branding agreement
with Northwestern's hospital corporation
so he ordered it censured he ordered it
taken down offline this had been
published this was not like he prevented
it it was already published and he took
it down I was told shut up don't say
anything we're gonna try to work this
out you know I'm not very good at shut
up to anything but I was worried about
my colleagues so I shut up and did
nothing and then they went on and on and
on and one of my other colleagues
started really questioning it that was
Christie Kirchner who's a physician and
a disability studies scholars in
rehabilitation medicine herself she had
written a piece for me for that issue
about women in women with disabilities
and how they take back their own
sexuality so Christie was increasingly
disgusted with the censorship as was I
you know I'm in the middle of publishing
Galileo's middle finger I literally
brought to the dean's office the book
jacket as it had been designed with all
these people praising me for advocating
for academic freedom
and Here I am being censored in my own
medical school and I'm supposed to say
quiet about this right so like they keep
telling me like well there's nothing
we're gonna do about it because we we
pay for it so we have the right to
decide and I I just kept saying them to
have you googled me like Do You Know Who
I am like I cannot put up with
censorship right like I have spent the
last several years fighting for academic
freedom and I'm not gonna put up with
this so finally what happened was
Christie resigned and then I ended up
trying to go to the provost office and
get them to reverse the decision they
did finally put bill pieces work back up
but they didn't say that it had ever
been censured and they never said
explain why disappeared for a while they
also required that from then on that the
journal had to be approved by the dean's
office and by the PR department and we
would have to get permission on the
themes permission on the call for
proposals permission on what we were
gonna publish they were gonna approve
everything and that's not academic
freedom in the least so I couldn't put
up with that so I resigned quite
publicly over it and called them out on
it and they never disagreed with my
version of the events in public they
never challenged it they basically
admitted that what I was saying was true
and they never apologized for it so
clearly that was the wrong exstrophy to
be so in the great sweep of irony if you
know if you know who northwestern's
chief rival is northwestern think since
their chief rival the other side doesn't
think they should bother having a rival
ship with northwestern but that is the
University of Chicago and I used to be
other faculty as it turns out that's
where my son is going in the fall as a
college student and I will say that when
I was there with him last and I was
walking across the green with him I was
incredibly jealous so jealous because
that wonderful intellectual life that
exists there is something I really do
miss it was a it was a beautiful thing
and that's why in that piece on the dark
web I say to people you know you are
where you need to be you don't need to
be in a dark web you should be in a
light web and that I think is true you
are kind of the Taylor Swift of academic
controversies at some point do you worry
is it you I think what's the reason I
get into these things is both because I
I'm kind of fearless and I
don't mind being uncomfortable a little
bit but the other thing is that I'm
articulate and when you're articulate
and willing to fight that gets you in a
lot of trouble so in the book I did the
book ala is a little finger I talk about
the galilean personality and that's not
to say I'm anywhere near of the
intellect Galileo is but it is to say I
have this similar personality to him as
do the other people I track in the book
who get in trouble and that is this
personality type that is unafraid of
fighting when they believe they that's
something they know to be true is being
denied they will fight and fight and
fight to try to get people to see what
they see and there are people who
believe that eventually the truth will
save them and they're stupid that way
because it's not good the book is named
after a literal digit of Galileo his
middle finger which is mounted on a
stone pillar under a glass jar pointing
forevermore at the heavens that is in
the Galileo Museum in Florence and you
know to me that's the story of like well
yeah technically he won but look what's
left of it right it's like a middle
finger he died under house-arrest it
sucked the truth is it sucks so I was
the people that your publisher worried
about I thought that the book was about
Galileo when I saw the cover and the
title because I knew about the finger I
had been in Florence and Jennifer my
wife and you know gone to the museum and
was raving about this little relic that
sort of the closest really a secular
version of the Catholic relics of the
saints right it is so it's fantastic no
I love I love the relic and I tell the
story in the book that when I came upon
in graduate school I just started
laughing hysterically cuz I thought is
so incredibly funny great that of all
the things left of Galilei and I was
middle finger pointing up this is just
so incredibly funny but it's also a
metaphor for there's just so much you
can do as an individual I mean there is
just so much you can do as an individual
you have to hope that you can move
people to look with you at what is true
and if you're right then they will find
what you found hopefully there won't be
mass hysteria you'll find what you find
and one of Galileo's men
Virtue's was that in some sense he was a
public intellectual in our current sense
right he wrote in the vernacular he
tried to reach people other than his
academic colleagues just sort of
finishing up here I me what how do you
view the role of the public intellectual
these days I know that in science there
is a whole separate category of science
popularizers
people who write books and have TV shows
and so forth and if you write a book or
appear on a TV show that popularizes
science then there's certain segments
that remove you from the list of active
intellectuals doing work right that so
clearly you've gone over to a different
side and the idea that you're both doing
research and doing your work and trying
to reach a bigger audience it's not a
category that they quite accept but I
suspect that in the humanities it's a
little bit more established that this is
something we can at least aspire to do
know I think there's the same suspicion
I'm guessing you're talking about
yourself running it since you like to
take post I know and I know personally
but I've heard of you so yeah I know
there there is that bias and I've always
assumed what that really is is jealousy
right that that's some form of well you
can do that but you can't do what I do
well and in fact there are people there
are some people who can do both really
really well and I think that's really ok
if they do both really well and you know
is it the case that some people dumb
stuff down too much in order to sell
books yes and that's regretful and that
should not happen but there are some
folks who stick with it stay in the
field they actually know don't wander
into fields they have no clue what
they're talking about and some of the
stuff that comes out of that is really
very good so you know I try hard when
I'm contacted by newspapers or broadcast
venues or whatever it is and they say to
me we want you to talk about X cuz here
you know you speak so clearly on this
and and I say them that's not really my
field you know you need to talk to this
person or that person and they're always
surprised but my own
feeling as if we're gonna do public
intellectualism well we should be very
careful to talk about what it is we
actually know and where the danger zone
comes in is when you have people who are
wandering into fields that they really
don't know what they're talking about
that is not good for intellectualism
that becomes mere punditry
it does seem though it's easy to do that
though because the places will let you
publish wherever you want they need they
need content now because the Internet
they need so much content there's so
much crap published and they don't know
who to ask right I there in my field
there is the famous example of Bill Nye
the Science Guy showing up on CNN as an
expert on climate change they fired all
their real science reporters that's what
they were left with and Bill Nye is
extraordinarily articulate and a good
champion of science he knows nothing
about - ain't he's certainly not a
researcher in that field so I have mixed
feelings like a good for him but he
could have said no employ them at
somebody who was a better choice and
there are plenty of people who are just
articulate yeah yeah exactly it's worth
making a little bit of an effort if
there are you know news producers out
there but I think you know I'm heartened
maybe I'm reading in so you should you
should verify or or fix this
misimpression after all of this after
all the controversies after all the
back-and-forth you you still seem to
cling to something that seems like an
optimistic view of the intersection or
union of being an intellectual and being
an activist of seeking both truth and
justice it's it's hard it's not linear
but it's worth the fight is that myself
a bitter optimist yeah no I think I
think that's right i like doing
intellectual work but I also feel like
we have a limited amount of time on
earth and we should spend that trying to
help improve the lives of others as we
are able I think it's a perfect place to
stop Alice dragger thanks so much for
joining us on the podcast
[Music]
you
[Music]